[Music]
[Applause]
welcome everyone to the most esteemed
meme review show in the world with me
i have the most esteemed co-host are you
hosting
what are you doing ksi hi i am here
i'm here wow this is weird
it is a big win it is a bit weird hey
what's your opinion on memes
i love memes i love memes i love um dark
humor memes
okay but obviously i try not to uh
mention it too much
okay well we have none of those okay all
right
i don't know anime memes what's that
anime
oh oh really do you like anime i love
anime oh hell yeah man what's your
favorite
uh right now i'm watching demon snare oh
hell yeah yeah yeah
oh dude yeah i didn't know that that's
awesome
yeah yeah yeah all right i don't have
any demonstrations you told me
do you have any anime please no no
you're going to be very disappointed
youtube surely youtube memes no no no i
just picked the
the latest and the freshest okay this is
the meme economy right now
sweet i'm here
[Music]
all right you're from uk indeed
british
all right so for some reason british
memes are popping up
so oh boy
okay we got this one we'll see how these
respond to you and okay
yeah okay i had 10. uh all right i'll
read the first one british people will
see this and think
he's got a siren for his egg write a
stupid in it
ah this is uh top of the
top of the range of leaves here
i'm gonna give that one an outpour yeah
hell yeah i'm giving an apple
i can't do it oh you got the outfit i
actually right but it's too big to fit
the camera
all right we have this phenomenal meme
uh from good old-fashioned spongebob
americans braces and as you can see
europeans are very afraid of the idea of
phrases
true uh i don't think that's true true
come on come on you cannot [ __ ] me
here
are you serious we're not afraid of
braces
well we'll see about that we got more
all right you should read this one
because i
i clearly can't do it ready i mean okay
at least i don't get short in
maths class when i'm doing
miss school ah this is a violation man
what is this can you explain this to me
because i don't understand the board
well i don't understand this all right
well
clearly some americans wrote this and
made
create this and decided to go oh yeah
all british people taught like this and
don't know how to properly speak with
their teeth for everywhere
what's shorts uh
i i know i get shot sure at least i
don't get short in maps
i don't know what the what the [ __ ] is i
don't i don't bro i'm
dude you're the british expert sure uh i
don't know
uh all right shot oh what
is this all just bridge to me so i'm
sorry god
british people be like hey loaf
you know it's true
that's a good one you know what okay
that's a very good one
halo free got the halo free
all right we'll see if you can relate to
this british people wake up in a bathtub
full of ice with their kidneys gone and
be like right
what's all this thing
yeah i like that you're so funny
yo
so tall like this one hey that's all
okay what's this british people be like
literally literally
literally right literally lit literally
like for me like i do a bit of slang
like fam
in it yeah don't know out here uh-huh
like do you i'm sure you don't know what
that end of that means yeah you don't
know any
what i don't know you know what don't
know means
don't know uh no no
it's like i don't know like oh yeah
you don't know no it's like oh yeah no
don't know
means no you don't know no done no like
done no like donna d-u-n-n-o
no done done no we're not getting
[Applause]
anywhere
that's rotted right all right all right
like a rant like really it's not it's
it's not
no it's like rotten is like it's mad
it's crazy
bruh i'm so white right now how about
i feel like you're just confirming what
these memes are saying
[Laughter]
british people be like this website
uses biscuits to improve use of
experience
what the that's outrageous
i'm pissed i'm pissed off
[Laughter]
i feel like the fact that you understand
what it means sort of speaks to you that
it's some sort of truth in it you know
what i mean
because i read this and i understand
anything oh you don't you don't get it
my equipment would be meatballs or
something [ __ ] i guess
do british people still do the accent
when nobody's around
okay now we can finally settle this
what taught me like this
i'd hardly ever no one's ever spoken
like that
no one speaks like that god damn it
british people okay
all right inviting you to the show when
i offend you
this is not mine british people be like
is that what you call it in your king
micro crisps i stay i live here eight
years and i still don't say crisp like i
don't get it
does that only be microchip no it's
michael crisps or new king
oh oh it's just
oh my god i hate british people
i'm sorry we got to get through this
hang in there
we got other memes don't worry
it'll be all right british people i like
how they quotation mark people
yeah like as if we're not real
when they find out americans don't call
potato chips that yeah
bloody jolly web bumper knuckle cod
swallow
bloody blame christmas
is that what you order do you want you
really want chips
yeah every time i go to mcdonald's man
i'm just like
bloody jolly what bomb knuckle cod
switches
please dude that was scary i couldn't do
that
yeah i'm impressed okay what is
this i want you to read this one
this looks like it's come from like a
harry potter game
it
you haven't played the original harry
potter game it's good yeah it's good oh
wow all right
all right brother we only found some
yeah
with me with me nudes and that
it's quite cheap in it five quid to see
me bomb
rather what is that word
come on that's how you spell it rather
stupid
not to write the cheers
is that accurate um
unfortunately no
there is oh my god what's her name there
is a female
who is british that like kind of speaks
like that
wait i know it i need to find out who's
set up yeah yo josh i've got an
emergency basically i need you to let me
know
who this woman is who is like really
crude and like says really vulgar things
and she's a female she's kind of funny
uh white
british yeah let me know
okay we can get back to it all right
we'll know if josh is a simpler knight
okay what's this oh my god
bro i came with the thief memes man well
british people have really good teeth
you know
i'm british and i'm decent teeth i mean
i had braces
i had you had brain cells yes i did have
braces oh
so no no don't don't
so this is accurate not accurate
it's it's well it it's it was accurate
when
i took them off because obviously i
didn't want to see them again
but at the time yes um i embraced it
i i had braces too it's okay okay all
right we're good we're good
we're good oh i found out who she is
okay okay
okay oh do i go sophie the slot
that was quick josh yeah yeah josh was
very fast
actually if anything ethan said it first
okay wait sophie the slot
oh the [ __ ] yeah and i'm saying you're
british
selfie the [ __ ] yes ah
just looking at my little piggies
through the cage
window oh
i can't believe it sophie is getting
it i can't i can't watch i'm sorry
that's worse than these memes
all right this is all teeth memes but
yeah wait wait wait wait wait wait
you why is that bandycam don't hey don't
don't hate on bandicam oh my god you
you still use bandicam
[Music]
all right we got more british memes how
do you even see i got bandicam that's
[ __ ] watching it
you're not supposed to die you're
spending again how do you see it
what do you usually record yes
everyone does that obvious is up today
my jesus
oh you might as well use fraps
what are you what do you rate the the
bridge
yeah i am british how did you guess
i wonder how you guess
that's all that british people look like
they're just cooking teeth
yeah let's see oh my god
have i hurt your feelings felix
i'm sorry no
it's all right it works
it works fine i don't need oh yes
i paid for this bandicam i'll get a
goddamn usage
i would rate british memes five out of
ten five out of ten okay
fine by the time it made me laugh but
it's a bit repetitive
yeah it's a bit repetitive especially
with the teeth
and the the accent but uh i guess that's
all they got biscuit
teeth braces braces calling crisps
chips no way see i don't get it still
what the [ __ ]
you know what it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter i just mad
all right what would you rate it andrea
is six
i mean what wait so you had a better
time than i did no
i'm changing mine to a seven you cannot
rate higher than me
i said my date then
okay fine fine god damn it oh
all right next name
are you ready i don't think you're ready
i don't know what to expect you're not
i'm getting right now i'm guessing
swedish memes oh no no
what i only pick these are just topical
i'm not i'm not going to do it
what you mean oh that's not there's
nothing what swedish people just perfect
we're just there's perfect yeah that's
it yeah thank you for staying there fill
in
[Music]
okay how'd you say perfect in swedish
yeah so how do you say in swedish
perfect perfect yeah okay
so what's it in swedish okay
are you ready for the next minute yes
i'm ready god damn it
i only have one out of this one it's a
two week old meme we're a little late on
it okay but this is a very popular meme
and i want to hear your opinion on
it okay
what what how did it get up there
i'm so confused i like how that
i like how you went straight to it yeah
how do you get up there
is his name juan is it the balcony where
are they
what's going on that's it that's the
mean that's the b
that's the main one
i would rate at 10.
yeah sure okay
yeah do you like one you can't trust me
on this one you can't write one
uh if you if you rate it low you're
gonna get
internet hitting on you okay okay it's a
ten it's a ten
nice nice next meme
how familiar are you with unizarnis oh
of course i know them yeah
it was yeah obviously yeah they're not
around no more but yeah it was
insane recently deleted rest in pieces
i can't believe they actually did it i
thought they were just control you
thought they were going to troll yeah
but they said that i mean i guess i did
the same thing a couple years ago
tonight
come on of course i've got to delete it
well yeah are you serious
well i mean it's just crazy because
rockefeller was just like
oh so what happened i was like but i
just
acted as if nothing just happened wait
you spoke to him after he wasn't in
tears
oh no no no i just saw his tweet no no
actually yeah yeah
i've never actually oh okay well
restaurant peas in his honest
obviously it was a big deal okay so
there was memes from it
okay all right we got the unes
annas okay the animation version
yeah yeah nice it was honest
deleting their channel me who never
watched the video and just found out
it's now a bad time to start watching
unizana's
is that actually other videos still
around
no i think they take them down yeah oh
man so they actively take down every
video
yeah mad that's that's the only way to
do it
yeah i respect it you
are one of the few people who watch unis
honest before it disappeared oh wow
i know i kind of it was a special moment
like
i was there like it was weird i woke up
i like
did you watch the live stream yeah i
watched it like 6 7 a.m oh
and i saw her and i was like wow it's
happening it just said deleted
the channel is deleted
there's no way i've legit falling in the
troll but i read it
it's it's this is a lot more wholesome
than i expected because i i only watch
like
a couple videos and i have no idea
what's going on
apparently it's a big deal
see this is you and then basically wait
who's
honest deletes the channel after one
year of saying that they
were going to delete the channel after
one year the fans
oh my god
yeah i can't believe they did what they
said they were gonna do
it's pretty smart though like they just
flew up from it
yeah i respect it we should like delete
our channels unasana's memes
i'll give him i'll give him an f for
respect
isn't that like a fail no f for respect
everyone knows that come on
i would never when when you made failure
when i got an
f in my a levels i didn't get respect
that's a good joke no come on you know
call of duty for respect right
okay that's what i meant not fair
i guess you would rate it in a then uh
i'll give it an a star
oh yeah all right you hear that
markiplier nathan eight star
well done well done can you do the next
meme clap for me
uh before we like okay next
[Music]
you meme damn it
okay there we go nice thank you ksi for
the double clap
all right okay i really like this next
meme it needs a little bit
of context though okay i still
understand how you saw him using
bandicam by the way
[Laughter]
how familiar are you with obamian i've
i've
never heard of this you've never heard
of a bamiyan i've never
well i can't blame you it's the rarest
material in existence
it's it's a material what it's a
material it was discovered by a
scientist
so wait is it part of the prereq
periodic table
you did get an f didn't you
[Laughter]
no stop reminding me
okay i'm sorry it was for respect i'm
sure
okay it was discovered in the lab just
like this
oh this is the live footage oh my god
what am i watching oh
the creation of aubameyang i just said
it what could you do with obama
it's this is rare you you did the onto
one question
it's just like it's about me come on
well anyway there's also
obamacare the uh
oktoberfiem i think this is octang
octangula obama obat obamtaku
yeah you like this
what's going on
what is this well anyway
i'm just giving you the context all
right what the hell was that
that's a sp spider bomber
uh it's a foldable version if you want
to make your own it's fake obviously
oh my god worth nothing uh
where's the what are we zooming in
i didn't mean to i'm full screen man
bandicam you know what it doesn't matter
okay so this this meme has been it's
been flirting around the internet
and it's rare don't worry i i don't
blame you for not knowing it
so now a different version come out of
it okay where it's basically
and i really need your help here okay
there's countries
right you know in football games or so
uh no way you've caught football games
yeah yeah
yeah you should call it football games
as well yeah yeah i'm just stupid okay
you know when they play and and you see
them and it becomes one thing right
oh yeah yeah plus italy okay
finally okay finally oh no i know i
i don't think you want to continue this
i i think i know where this is going all
right so next one
[Laughter]
india india
spain finally in pain
okay nice i want to live there
what india in spain oh god damn it
your turn
[Music]
[Laughter]
it was a glorious day
uh nigeria germany finally
my favorite country oh yeah
china what what the [ __ ] is that
let's what's that less though is that a
real one
we both failed geography apparently is
that a real country
we're probably offending the like two
fans
southern africa oh bad i had no idea
what how does that make chile oh chile
yeah of course i'm stupid
oh yeah yeah this is tickle your funny
bone
usa india finally
you're saying yeah yeah
oh god why is it always the same black
doctor
because he's oh that's a good question
actually he's just finding out all these
all these elements he's so smart
bangladesh america finally
bang erica hey
someone named erica is very happy right
now iceland cuba
finally ice i want to live there
i don't want to die i'll check it out
it's a bit cold this year
[Laughter]
okay all right maybe two obscure i feel
like
what about this one then finally center
text
uh what
what
[Music]
serbia yemen finally semen yes
are you still there yeah i'm here can i
rate this into that one
no no no i why are these leaves mine
oh come on all right well i will
i will rate it in six
it's six yeah it's funny and you gave
the british memes
five no i gave it a seven i changed it i
ate actually
finally finally that's really funny come
on okay yeah bye
i'll give it to you hey my man
you know we can't do ksi meme review
without some
classic oh though okay oh my god yeah
yeah oh god i don't even know what to
expect from this
oh well i just went i just went through
your reddit and i have i have some
questions oh no
oh no i can't believe that man please
i thought it's safe here this one made
me laugh at least
oh my god
wait do you have a hamster yeah yeah
yeah i've got two oh hell yeah
oh hell yeah i got a hedgehog you got a
hedgehog
yeah oh mad they need to race
would your hedgehog eat my hamster no
it's tiny
how do you get the camera in there uh
okay how about this one
i noticed i noticed i i'm going through
you already there's a lot of jokes
based on your appearance
yeah it kind of um
[Music]
it kind of makes me wonder like how i
got this far
i like this one i mean these make me
laugh at me
yeah village i've come for a roast
oh this one isn't a meme okay yeah that
that chicken butt that just happened
yeah i gotta ask you though so what felt
bad at that moment
or just being here hosting technically
sort of
meme review yeah um what was better i
think it's it's
it's it's very tough um between you know
obviously training
for many months for that one moment and
obviously
training for years and years for this
moment
yeah and without a doubt it has to be
this moment
okay god would satellite you heard it
here first thank you
thank you i i don't see you on the
camera but i imagine we're
yeah i'm celebrating as hard yeah
yeah oh for god's sake
are we true
is it true it is it may be true
okay the baby tree i'm glad we're
getting all these yeah it's not like
but they they use like what i think
it's like twizzlers or something those
are hot flaming hot cheetos
you should know you they're on your head
okay i love this what the [ __ ] is this
oh
mate someone went through a load of maps
to see bro let me know i'm actually not
six foot yeah
you're not even six five i'm not six
foot oh yes i know
they've they've sussed it out and
realized that's
involved i wait so how long how tall i'm
five eleven
yep but i'm 511. what so we're the same
height
we're the same height oh my god dude can
we just start
lying and say that we're six foot no one
will know yes except people they do this
we'll blur this no one will yeah yeah
like i think i
i'm sure i'd delete that well i guess i
didn't yeah let's delete that we'll
delete this
it's [ __ ] he's trying to expose oh
it's ridiculous look at the mouse
you're clearly six fight man with poland
einstein all over
my ass dude oh no that's
it that's it yeah that's all the ksi
memes yeah
thank god oh wait wait wait wait what is
this what is this sorry there's one more
what
why is there one more no wait one more
one
no let's just
[Music]
i do have a virtual yeah you're trying
to up me what no i'm not trying to help
you i'm trying to learn how to play
it okay well case i i have an instrument
even better than the french horn no way
okay no
please that's the [ __ ] block
flute
the what flute the black flint what is
that
okay
[Music]
you recognize science that's a black
play
you've got the recorder it's not oh
sorry record it sorry that's what it's
called
sorry i forgot you're british that's my
my apologies mate
so what you've just got it for all the
bad flute memes hey why don't we jam out
there's an end of this what's your
favorite song celine dion
my heart will go wait i could have
practiced how to turn
my my wife martin she knows how to play
oh really
terrible
okay you do the alpha and then okay you
ready
yeah i'll count i'll count as in three
two one
[Music]
me
thanks ksi thank you so much for posting
co-hosting whatever you want to call it
i appreciate you coming on here it was a
pleasure
guys subscribe to ksi if you haven't
already
what just happened yeah i never know
which channel to shout you out or like
look you oh
then jd wonder just just type in random
black dude then you might find me
on that note that's it this has been
meme
review please you can do the clap now
oh yes free review we've hosted many
celebrations since the launch of this
most relevant of games
we look far and wide to bring you the
most up-to-date and interesting topics
but then there is one subject that we
somehow missed
welcome home my tuber friends every home
is different and love is central to
every one of them
it's a theme that is sure to appear in
our room events i look forward to
virtually visit your dwellings